Marvel's Doctor Strange had the enormous task
of introducing big magic to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
You know, same reality as Captain America
and Iron Man and other science-based heroes.
Even Scarlet Witch is explained as using "cosmic
energy" when she does her thing, so Doctor
Strange explores some weird new places for
our heroes.
And fans and critics agree that it does so
really, really well.
But despite having a compelling story and
mind-blowing visuals to boot, the film still
had a few head-scratchers that you just can't
wave a magic wand at.
Here are a few plot points that not even Steven
Strange could explain.
Missing magicians
When Strange is going through his training
in Kamar-Taj, there are a boatload of other
would-be wizards taking on the same drills
and learning the same magic alongside him.
It's a whole wizard army, just ready to be
set loose on any mystical threats, ranging
from Kaecilius to David Blaine.
So...where were all these folks when Kaecilius
attacked the Sanctums?
The Ancient One knows that the bad guy is
going to try and take out the Sanctums.
So why is only one dude hanging out all by
himself as a defender?
They have the numbers to set up a platoon
of wizards at each Sanctum in case of an assault,
even if those trainees don't yet have full-on
magic mojo yet.
A lack of training has never stopped fellow
baldy Professor X from throwing kids at the
bad guys.
It's never stopped Batman.
And it shouldn't have stopped an all-out war
against Kaecilius.
Only the Surface
Like most big blockbusters, Marvel movies
have never been afraid of clunky product placement.
Just ask everyone in Civil War about their
weird Vivo phones.
In Doctor Strange, things are a bit more subtle,
but one noticeable little moment sticks out
like a sore thumb.
Strange is a world-renowned doctor, and he's
pretty dang rich because of it.
He doesn't skimp on the cars that he haphazardly
drives around mountains, and his extravagant
New York City apartment must cost millions.
So, why does Stephen Strange use a Surface
3 tablet?
The Surface 3 is basically the Toyota Corolla
of the computer world.
It's fine, but it's far from the best if you
have an unlimited budget.
Strange couldn't even spring for a Surface
Pro?
That's weak stuff, Doc.
Chain gang
The movie kicks off with Kaecilius stealing
spells from the library at Kamar-Taj in order
to summon Dormammu.
It's clear that these books are extremely
dangerous … and they're only protected by
some … loose chains?
It's basically Level One wizard stuff to make
a portal, so it's clear that the chains aren't
there for protection.
That's why they have librarians … which
seems to be the most dangerous job in the
whole joint.
After the initial head-chopping scene, we
see our man Wong in the library, protecting
the books.
Unfortunately, Wong isn't, y'know, great at
his job.
Technically, no knowledge is forbidden in
Kamar-Taj.
But would it be so crazy to protect these
books a little better?
Obviously, a regular vault wouldn't be immune
to wizard portals, grabby hands, or even your
standard Hamburglar.
But these guys have the most powerful magic
on Earth at their disposal!
There's gotta be a magic force field spell
in one of these books, right?
Sometimes the honor system just doesn't work,
okay?
Deus ex magica
It's hard to overlook the film's most absurd
coincidence: Doctor Strange dives into a book
alllll about time manipulation — only moments
before Kaecilius attacks.
It's perfect timing in the worst possible
way.
Where the heck has Kaecilius been during all
this time while Strange is training?
Kaecilius steals the pages for his spell in
the first moments of the movie, then waits
months to stage his next attack.
All he did was allow the Ancient One more
time to plan, train Strange, and beef up their
defenses.
Which ... they kind of failed at anyhow.
Time and time again
Mordo spends most of the movie warning Strange
over and over about messing around with time,
noting it can result in everything from the
end of the world to severe constipation.
"Temporal manipulations can create branches
in time.
Unstable dimensional openings!
Spacial paradoxes!
Time loops!"
But later Strange uses the Eye of Agamotto
to rewind downtown Hong Kong to a time before
the local sanctum falls, in an effort to save
the day.
He then cleverly mucks around with a time
loop to stop Dormammu in his tracks.
"Dormammu!
I've come to bargain.
Dormammu!
Dormammu!"
If messing around with an apple was dangerous,
you'd think erasing the destruction of an
entire city is flirting with all-out cosmic
disaster, right?
But after all those warnings from Mordo, there
are no immediate consequences for Strange's
actions.
Everything seems...fine.
Even still, Mordo seems to know what's up…
"You still think there will be no consequences,
Strange?
No price to pay?"
… but let's see Infinity War try to write
itself around legit time travel.
Magic Mordo-torium
By the end of the film, Mordo's got a brand
new bag.
His new mission is to go around and take magic
away from people who use it, since too much
unchecked magic honestly seems like a pretty
bad idea.
So, Mordo can apparently just take away magic
now?
That ability sure would've come in handy a
bit earlier.
Y'know.
When the dude with all the magic power was
straight up trying to end the entire world.
Unless of course, Mordo can only suck the
magic out of low-level Dumbledores, like the
guy with the spine problems… which is a
pretty crappy magic trick.
It's the magic equivalent of stepping on bugs:
I mean, it's pointless, and it only feels
good if you're a jerk.
Mordo should pick on someone his own power
level.
Guess we'll have to wait for Doctor Strange
II: Magic House Call for that.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!